my plan is to talk about four things
this afternoon first the status of us
climate regulation as it relates to the
electric power industry the second is
new developments in environmental
regulation other than climate change as
it affects the electric power industry
third I'm going to talk about some
recent developments at the Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission and finally
some legal issues concerning related
energy matters now let's take a look at
where the u.s. is right now so the US
has been in an expansion so the
recession is over technically the
recession is technically over but GDP is
stagnant we're going to talk about
Chinese outward direct investment in the
United States here but we're really
going to talk about more than just that
issue because what that is showing us is
what level of maturity Chinese companies
are at the rise of China intersects with
a moment in the American consciousness
where we're thinking about ourselves as
in decline which has been really i think
sharply exacerbated by the partisan
gridlock in Washington the current level
of partisan conflict at least in in my
lifetime and in the last 50 years of
American political history is really
extraordinary and you know in another
couple of weeks we're going to be up to
seven billion those people have to go
somewhere I mean the idea that they have
no impact on resources are on the
planets ecosystem is just ludicrous the
plan is not that big it's big butts that
fact the idea of governments intervening
taking control and in a sense taking
over major private institutions in times
of crisis is something which is
fundamentally acceptable
the European historical psychic it is
something which is fundamentally
unacceptable and shocking in the United
States I think the answer is an urban
density no question but when we do that
we can't isolate people from nature it's
where we feel good it's where we're at
our best so I think the other issues of
urban agriculture by Ophelia's the
terminology that we use are very very
important as we plan for a green and
sustainable future my work is really
about light it's all about understanding
the phenomenology of light primarily
daylight but also artificial light and I
became involved in working with light as
a medium basically in the late 1960s
when is in school and that basically led
me into glass as a material to capture
and manifest and sort of explorer
qualities of light so technically in the
next three or four years we will be able
to allow a car to go door-to-door
driving itself it would sense
pedestrians it would sense bicyclists it
would handle all forms of traffic and
intersections so of course that the next
generation of planning software will be
able to do that automatically so you get
from the satellite image to some kind of
planning model without the handwork but
cities seem to be efficient yet there
are many many problems there in living
there if you can address some of those
issues that we're talking about here
you're touching on some of the core
problems of the planet right there the
problems of cities if we all move there
are converging with the bigger problems
of the planet today the politics of this
is that the fossil fuel industry in the
u.s. is very big and very powerful it's
been able to block any moves to tax the
use of fossil fuels so instead the
government has had to move to
subsidizing non-fossil fuels when you
see some of that in Europe obviously in
germany in spain and italy for the
feed-in tariffs but that's basically the
main policy paper here in the US
subsidizing non-fossil fuels and this so
you can think of this as kind of couples
therapy for the marriage between science
and policy and we we work very much at
that interface um we can link air
quality concerns and climate concerns
are much more easily now but i would
like to argue that it is actually
possible to get co2 back out of the air
at a price you can afford and if that's
true it opens all sorts of interesting
options you can you can make fuels out
of it or you could bury it depending on
what you want to do with it what EDF has
been supporting that is the Alliance
program is a program that involves every
part of columbia all of our 9
professional schools and the arts and
sciences which include the doctoral
programs and our undergraduate college
as well this means that it's the most
important program I think of academic
and cultural exchange that we have with
any other part of the world and it
brings Columbia together with three
French institutions who are wonderful
partners